made fun of it at the top of the show
because we didn't really know how else
to respond but joe biden really has
crossed over into a very dangerous very
dangerous place tonight he declared in a
speech in philadelphia that anyone who
disagrees with him is a threat
to the country here's part of what biden
said too much of what's happening in our
country today is not
normal
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our republic that
the republican party today is dominated
driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
yeah they're a threat says the guy with
a blood-red nazi background and marines
standing behind him it's a complete
outrage that this is being sanctioned as
a white house event in other words that
this is the approved position of our
government it's totally immoral and then
the guy who encouraged riots in 2020
accused maga republicans of somehow
threatening the rule of law in the
united states watch this
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election
and they're working right now
as i speak in state after state
to give power
to decide elections in america to
partisans and cronies
empowering election deniers to undermine
democracy itself
maga forces are determined
to take this country backwards
they promote authoritarian leaders and
they fan the flames of political
violence
that are a threat
to our personal rights
to the pursuit of justice
to the rule of law to the very soul of
this country
this is truly nuts and threatening to
the future of the united states it's
hard to believe he just did that but he
did
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight